welcome everyone I am Shai and I'm super
excited to present at my third straight
Pata Global conference if you are
interested to also look at some of my
previous sessions on drin some of the
open source projects uh they'll be
available on the YouTube for p data
Global uh so today's uh talk is about
how you can enhance your zy lab
developer experience with local large
language model support and code Snippets
uh so quick introduction about myself
I'm a tpjs Sig working with lead and I'm
a developer Advocate at pces for
developers as well uh and today of
course you'll be understanding that what
are some of the major pain points that
data scientists or even uh developers
who are using theer lab face on a
day-to-day basis and how they can
leverage the use of local large language
models for enhanced privacy and Cote
Snippets that allows uh overall seamless
developer experience especially when
you're working in large developer teams
and we'll identify those issues and then
how you can leverage some uh tooling
that is available to everyone uh in
order to enhance your experience when
basically developing as a data scientist
and specifically uh when it comes to
Zyer lab so first uh right at the bat
like let's understand the pain points
for data scientists when using notebooks
so of course uh you know organizations
have worked to build teams of data
Specialists to tackle tough problems
right and of course uh as software
Juniors we are traditionally using IDs
which are integrated development
environments and generally when it comes
to like competitional notebooks such as
the figher Google collab uh aw stemer
data bricks these are the primary tools
for data scientists and if you
understand you know like IDs basically
reflect a software programming Legacy
whereas like data science actually
reflects a very different ex size from
traditional software gening because data
scientists you know they must Wrangle
data produce analysis share results and
then productionize all of them by
themselves and this workflow is not only
like having many steps but it requires
interacting with multiple stakeholders
when you are trying to get data you are
probably interacting with a lot of like
data Specialists who are giving you that
data and of course once you want the
model to go into production you you're
basically collaborating with your uh
envelops or your data science or your uh
you know your uh devops teams which will
productionize that particular model so
uh there are certain you know
limitations when it comes to using uh
notebooks right so of course like
cleaning and loading the data can be
like a very painful process a very timec
consuming process because uh you know
you might uh have to download your data
from Cloud to load to local sources I
have to continuously reupload them uh
try to use multiple M libraries to clean
your data as much as possible but you're
never too sure because like let's say
even if there are some deficiency in in
your data then you will probably might
have to re like you know rewrite all of
that particular logic again to clean
that data and then of course when it
comes uh you know uh when it comes to
like large data sets they can cause
inconsistencies also uh in notebooks
then the most important of the I think
like one of the biggest drawbacks of
using something like notebooks or even
like theup lab there's no easy way to
collab elaborate so let's say if you're
sharing if you're writing an in to end
machine learning pipeline or data
science pipeline uh you want to quickly
share your code with some other
developer you might have to take that
particular code you'll copy it probably
paste it in a Google doc or in a slack
message and uh the other developers with
whom you're collaborating they might not
have any context to that particular uh
piece of code like let's say you're
trying to visualize some kind of data
science diagram and uh there's no
you know there's no correlation or
context being given to that and then of
course uh you know when you're trying to
like reproduce results and reusing code
they are not very easy task right uh so
those are some of the common main pain
points that we typically see uh because
of course even when it comes like
reproducing results uh like let's say if
someone else were to reproduce notebook
results they'll have to ensure that all
of their environment settings are the
same uh and moreover uh you know you
might have to understand that like data
scientists basically have to rerun the
same analysis on new data or follow the
same workflow across multiple projects
and this basically ends up like taking a
lot of like time because reusability is
not given to you by default when using
something like Zyer lab notebook or any
other notebook for that matter and this
problem basically goes beyond just
notebooks so let's say that there's a
scenario where a data scientist uh has
reported that you know that the model
performance is not great so they will
have to probably share that particular
piece of code with some ml Engineers now
the ml Engineers might not instantly
have you know uh context about that
particular uh code that is being written
so especially like the biggest issue
when it comes to like collaborating with
multiple folks is that when you do not
have context when sharing these quod
Snippets and generally like the code
Snippets that you'll be sharing will be
through you know either screenshots or
it will be through slack messages right
and again it's a very messy process to
share all these SC especially for data
scientists right uh there's very limited
collaboration uh when you're using
normal ways of uh you know collaborating
with other data scientists working on
the same project so like one example
would be that you are sharing your
Google collab collab notebook now Google
cab notebooks probably can be shared
across teams but again uh you'll not be
sharing context like let's say if
there's a new uh data scientist member
who joins the team uh immediately like
they'll not have like you're and you're
giving them a very large notebook to
work with they'll not have context about
that particular notebook and it might
take them time to understand each and
every particular uh part of that
particular your python notebook that has
that particular machine learning code
right so this leads to like
communication gap and uh you know you
cannot really very easily test those
particular cour temps easily uh inside
of notebooks or across teams so
especially when it comes like onboarding
of new developers uh new data scientists
into your uh project or even like
sharing of issues that you're facing
right uh whether it's with with respect
to data analysis all of that that can be
a very uh time consuming you know uh
timec consuming uh piece so uh those are
some of the common pain points that we
often see when we are dealing with uh
code Snippets or we are dealing with you
know collaboration across different data
science teams and of course uh you know
the key challenges right is that we saw
that you know copy pasting of your code
uh then of course uh you know ensuring
that there's a test coverage that you
are also having in of an entire project
um of course resolving bugs with a large
un unfamiliar code base especially for
new team members right that can also be
an issue uh maintaining code quality
might also be an issue if there are new
developers they might write their own
way of writing code logic so ensuring
that code quality remains consistent
across your entire team uh especially
even when you're like you know writing
code because see one thing to keep in
mind is that uh people you know might
think of data scientists and they might
take them for granted uh a lot of data
scientists still have to follow good
software development practices like
writing good quality code uh a lot of
like machine learning code also now
comes with a lot a lot of like test
cases so you know uh basically over time
a lot of like software engineering
practices are now also being followed
when writing machine learning code or
data science code right even if you're
working with uh notebooks you have to
follow good coding practices ensure that
when your model goes into production it
can follow all the different edge cases
so all these like challenges are like
you know go beyond this data scientists
and of course are also followed across
uh machine learning and standard
software development right so of course
like these are some of the challenges
that we continuously face so uh in order
to basically you know address like how
can we make sharing of all these Scot
Snippets or even uh sharing the context
of your entire you know uh project
itself amongst team members so that a
it's easier to onboard new members
whenever you're sharing some quotes
inipit there's some additional context
that you can actually give to that
particular codeit for example if you're
sharing uh a confusion Matrix related
code block from your project U the other
developers might already have context to
What that particular confusion Matrix is
based on so what was that initial input
data on the basis of which that
particular confusion Matrix was
generated if you can give that
additional logic or you know background
and context that can save up a lot of
time for other members to then
collaborate and help you out right so it
overall helps us to improve the
communication especially amongst members
who are working across different teams
or cross functional teams as well
because data scientists are going to be
working in a lot of times in cross
functional aspects so these are some of
the main reasons why you know uh current
uh ways of implementing the battle lab
or even for data scientist is not the
most uh straightforward of the easiest
but of course by sharing course with
context uh that can basically solve a a
lot of these particular problems right
and that is where I like to quickly
introduce a tool which is like pieces
which allows you to basically uh have a
centralized storage for all of your
different course Snippets it can not
only like generate course Snippets but
it can also like give you context about
those particular course Snippets as well
and uh within you know uh if you kind to
understand that a lot of the pain points
that we kind of understood with respect
to sharing of cot Snippets basically is
taken care when we are basically sharing
because you can efficiently share code
Snippets uh you know take any piece of
code that you have uh probably that
confusion Matrix particular code block
um generate an intelligent generated
code snippet from it and then just share
it across because you could not just
have just one particular code block but
you could also generate a code snippet
for your entire project itself and then
share it across different teams uh it
will have context to What that
particular C andit is it intelligently
Define that for you right and it can you
can just share that across by sharing
like a sharable link which can be then
shared across others and that particular
sharable link will not only carry what
is there in that particular code block
but also have context associated with it
right and then of course uh you can
basically uh integrate that with another
piece of code which is the pieces SC
pilot which basically essentially means
that um similar to a chat GPT because of
course a lot of us you know might be
implementing chat GPT to ask a question
to you know uh for example like let's
say you're stuck on a bug and then you
end up asking Char gbt like hey um how
could could I resolve this particular
issue you might get a response and then
you know you might end up using that
particular response but of course one of
the security concerns by while using
that kind of Strat GPT is that um not
every particular team might uh be
interested in sending their data privacy
Focus data to chat gbd because um and
that's the security concern for a lot of
like data science teams uh So pces Co
pilot also can use local large language
models which are open source as well for
example code Lama or Lama 2 and you can
basically then run your entire end to
endend uh Co like you know CH GPD like
experience but get explainability of
your code try to ask that particular
co-pilot that hey rephrase uh you know
that particular code um you know
rephrase that particular code it will do
that for you solve particular bug it
will go ahead and do that for you so all
by using local large language models so
that you use open source models and at
the same time you use them locally in
your system so that you are not having
any concern having to send your data to
a remote server or to chat gbt for that
matter right so that is what can be
handled with the help of pces Scope
Pilot and we'll see this demonstration
right now how this can basically work
and the great thing is that pieces
basically comes uh you know with a
number of different uh extensions so uh
pieces comes with it's Standalone uh you
know local um local uh desktop
application but there are a number of
different extensions that are also
supported uh and one of them is for Zyer
lab as well and yes so we'll now go
through a concrete example uh where
we'll understand that how you can
basically leverage uh this for your own
demonstration so I I'll quickly show
show all of your demonstration so for
example let's say that I want to use you
know a particular uh you know and for
this let me share my screen over here
let's say I want to quickly take a look
at a notebook for Iris data set let's
say I want to uh try to work on an iris
data regation can classification data
set so I'll go to kagle as anyone might
and let's say I'll just go ahead and uh
you know download this particular
notebook that I have so let's quickly uh
go ahead and download this particular
notebook and now I'll open up my uh
theer lab and I'll go ahead and click on
new and I'll uh basically uh go ahead
and open up a new uh notebook over here
so let's go ahead and click on new and
I'll open up a new notebook uh for
example in this case let's try to use
that particular Iris uh one that I just
downloaded so it's this one right so
it's this particular Iris uh discard
this particular over here so I have this
particular uh now this particular
notebook that is being powered right so
I'm using my standard theal lab uh
interface uh just give me
one sorry for that so now let's uh uh
take a look at this particular
interface um so now uh let's go ahead
and I will uh so this is my notebook and
I'll just start to run start to run it
right let's uh just execute all the
different steps that I have in this case
uh I'll just download the RS St set and
also run
this so this is a sample uh data you
know set that I'm using Iris data you
know as any scientist like would
probably start off with now for example
immediately what I see over here is that
um I see that you know I get this error
that no module named esarn do cross
validation so now this is where I will
introduce the pieces extension so you
can find that inside of the extensions
so you can take a look at the Jer lab
pieces extension which is this
particular uh extension that we'll be
using so in this case um when I again
share my tab you can see that the
extension is towards the right hand side
and over here I basically have this
interface where I can interact with a
co-pilot and over here by default you
can see that the model which with which
I'm running it is GPD 3.5 which is
basically a cloud-based model so you can
select between whether you want an on
device model that is running locally so
in this case uh for on device models I
have option of both llama 2 and of uh
code Lama so for instance like let's say
I want to change the context I don't
want to send my data to a uh chat GPT or
to an open a server I can use the local
large language model which is Lama 2 so
I select that and now my active model
that I'm going to be using the large
language model is Lama 2 so all
interactions now that will happen with
my co-pilot so this is like my personal
sgpd but all is being powered locally in
my system now what I can do is I can
simply just go Ahad over here and say
that I want to set the context for this
entire notebook inside of my cop viot so
I can set the context over here I'll
click on context I will select which
particular file I want the context to be
set for so in this case I'll go ahead
and add the context for this new
notebook that I just added and basically
what would happen is that this uh my
large language model will have the
context to my entire notebook now I can
also set context for just one function
or for one code block uh in this case
now I can simply go ahead and ask it
that hey uh
I'm facing this particular issue and
I'll right click and I'll ask pces SC
pilot over here and I'll say that I am
getting uh this issue about uh no module
named um es
skillon do cross validation right um and
then it will basically start to give me
a response so it will say uh it will
probably take like a few seconds so
based on this it says that you know uh
based on this particular train test
split uh we don't have you know the
particular module is no longer available
now like let's if I set the context as
probably open AI with uh gp4 I can also
you know ask the same question to it uh
probably I'm getting this issue over
here so I can ask it uh again and like
just ask it like how should I solve this
particular issue uh because I'm getting
this particular you know modu name
so perhaps like you know you can see
that I'm getting this error so it will
direct me to say that okay like if
you're using cross validation that's
probably an old one because now you know
uh for uh install of like cross
validation we'll probably end up using
model selection so if I use model
selection over here uh you can probably
then uh end up resolving this particular
issue so if I run this now then it will
run so the idea really is that you know
what you can essentially do is that you
have have your own personal chat GPD uh
in front of you and directly inside of
your uh Z zy lab so you don't have to uh
navigate somewhere else to like stack
oflow or to you know Google to try to
find uh some error that you're facing
inside of your code block for example uh
like let's say uh over here uh you know
if I execute uh all the rest of you know
the programs and uh for instance like
let's say I I'm making a prediction and
I'm uh basically
like you know uh generating like a
confusion Matrix so over here in this
case like in this particular confusion
Matrix I'm just returning but let's say
I want to visualize this particular uh
Matrix so I can ask another question to
it uh can you help um visualize uh this
particular U you know this particular
Matrix uh this confusion Matrix let's
see with um probably with a diagram so
perhaps it will give us like you know
some kind of suggestion on um you know
probably like cbon so it says like you
can use cbon and uh over here it will
basically give you some code
demonstration that okay like if you want
to visualize your uh you know your
particular uh uh confusion Matrix and
again like we can probably just go ahead
and copy this and see if it actually
works um and see over here so for
example like let's say I I'll go ahead
and copy this particular code over here
so I can use pieces to copy this over
here and then let's uh paste this
particular confusion Matrix and see if
it actually like you know will work so
I'll just uh basically uh you know print
uh I'll just uh basically comment the
above code and just try to run if it
works so now it does generate our
confusion Matrix so as a data scientist
I did not have to spend time like
writing that particular code on my own
but all of like I I just gave it a
prompt and it basically did that for me
but this is of course like working
locally just personally now what I can
do is I can also you know go ahead and
save this particular uh code snippit to
pieces and also share it with anyone so
instead like normally what would have
done is I would have copied this
particular code if I'm facing some issue
in it I will perhaps now copy this share
it in a slack message that hey uh Z I'm
facing this issue I'm facing ER an error
in this or I would have taken a
screenshot of this particular issue and
shared it but now I can just take this
particular code uh use that particular
uh generated code over here for example
this is my shared code that you know has
uh and what you can see is that it
basically gives all this particular uh
additional information about that
particular code it gives me that it's a
Python program it gives me a description
that this particular code creates a plot
of confusion Matrix using C B and mat
plot lip and it displays the result as
predicted or truth so it gives you not
only the information about who shared it
a brief description about this
particular cod in bit but also it gives
you some related links that hey um
because this particular code is related
to something like mat plot lip so you
might want to give it some additional
more context so for example it gives you
some related links about Matt lib about
you know cbon so again giving more
context to data scientists for sharing
these scits amongst each other right so
these are some real world like examples
on how you can like L really leverage
and again being privacy focused uh if
you don't want to use uh perhaps you
know that GPD you could basically
convert this model into one of the local
large langage models and be completely
free because of course Lama 2 is an open
source model and uh you can leverage
that so even if you don't have internet
connection uh you can leverage and get
that same similar CH GPT like experience
right inside of your Zyer lab right and
of course uh you can have context of all
the previous conversations that you have
similar to chat GPD so all the different
conversations uh for example yesterday I
was just like you know going through uh
asking chat GPT like as a way to kind of
prepare my presentation like what are
some of the daily challenges that you
know dat scientists face so some of the
content that is inated for my slides but
also inspired by some of the results I
got and again they were implemented by
using the local large language model
because I didn't have access to my
internet I was in a flight um and of
course like you know you can basically
go to any of your previous code and the
great thing is that this particular
context will be shared amongst the
different Integrations that are there so
if like let's say your uh you know your
uh devops team is using vs code so you
could basically open up an instance of
vs code have that same uh you know
experience and context being set across
different platforms now there's another
really interesting piece to this for
example like let's say uh I'm going
through gagle I'm going through a
particular you know uh I'm just looking
at this particular data set and for
example I come across a particular piece
of code perhaps uh like let's say I'm
going to M Matt plot lip documentation
so I go to Matt plot lip uh I'm going
through you know the documentation over
here um now let's say uh I'm going
through the documentation I I'll quickly
go to like let's say some tutorials um
probably uh you know take an example of
a quote snippet for uh like let's say
intermediate like styling with cycler uh
and I want to understand that hey like
what is this particular code I I I want
to understand that so I could basically
just ask co-pilot right inside of my uh
inside of my window as well so I can
just open up a side window and basically
uh I think like I'm not sure if it's
sharing but let me stop sharing and
share my entire screen uh so over here I
could basically give it some additional
context and you know ask it like for
example in this case pces go pces co
pilot is giving me this additional
context about hey like uh I can ask at
any particular website and it will
basically give me context to What that
particular code logic is right so in
this case like what is basically
happening is I'm giving it some
additional context uh about uh from a
particular website itself and it is able
to get context and now I can save this
particular uh code logic that I
basically have and it will have context
to this particular code so and what I
can do is uh you know I can simply go
ahead and copy this particular code as
well I can save it to Pieces as well
like I can if you want I can uh save it
as well uh in any particular past so I
can save this particular snippit I can
share it anywhere that I want so of
course all this then can also like for
example if I save it now uh I want to
use it right I want to save it U I can
save it and then I can basically go
ahead and you know uh basically try to
get that same particular code snippit
that I uh used uh over here inside of my
uh like for example over here you can
see that I had basically saved this from
uh a person but now I have context to
that same particular code inside of my
ziter lab as well so the great thing is
that for example if you're researching
about some particular code as a
scientist like if you're doing some kind
of research um you can try to uh like
use that research and store it in a
centralized place and access that entire
research inside of a z lab again share
it across different teams so that is one
of the major benefit when it basically
comes and again I'll quickly uh share my
screen uh to you know to my particular
uh demonstration over here um so of
course like just understanding like what
we have understood so far is that you
know like when opening the code and then
of course like copy pasting it uh that
takes up a lot of time right and like
let's say if you are having to and that
also what ends up happening is that
basically uh you might reuse certain
pieces of code again and again so copy
pasting that same code again and again
can be very timec consuming but of
course like with this implementation
having a centralized storage for all of
your Cod andits makes it very easy to
just reuse code as well and then of
course uh with co-pilot right uh
especially for security concerned or
security related concerns when it comes
like using llms um that's also one area
where by using local llms you get
privacy focused as well so you can just
open up aital notebook ask copilot to
basically ask all of your doubts and of
course like having to go to different
websites like five six different
websites uh and trying to find that
particular same related issue might be a
very timec consuming but since the
copilot has access to your entire code
base um it makes it very easy for you to
then just understand that context and
get direct results from the copilot
while sitting inside of your jit lab
instance itself right uh so inclusion
like basically let's ditch screenshots
and copy pasting and basically share
context of code Snippets with context to
have better Clarity amongst different
team members as well uh so of course now
I'll be open to any questions
so I think uh let me see if there are
any questions um I think there's one
question yeah in the Q&A just want to be
mindful of time we are at the top of the
hour so if we could do that and then we
can citate this discussion to Discord as
well but let's get that one question
quickly answered yeah and by the way
like uh for those folks like it is
pieces. apppp like I think like that is
the link and then question is how has it
to install and set up pieces for a team
so basically if you're if you're working
inside of a team there's this uh
specific thing called as uh you know um
basically the uh related peoples so as a
team you can as an Enterprise you can
basically set the context and Nishan is
asking can you set context across a
whole G repository uh so that is
completely possible because U you can
log into your pces account with GitHub
as well and then GitHub will uh give
access to pieces to your all of your
different code repositories if you want
and it can set context across and entire
G repository as well you can set context
not just for a single file for a single
function for a file for an entire you
know code snippit for entire folder as
well so yes that can be done and of
course like if if you have any further
questions you can connect with me on
Twitter uh but yeah if there are any
other further questions uh feel free to
like you know connect with me and I'll
be more than happy to answer any of
those particular questions